au moment de choisir un endroit pour
accueillir la rencontre entre joe biden
et vladimir poutine plusieurs pays
étaient pressentis comme l'autriche ou
encore la finlande là où s'étaient
rencontrés pour la première fois la dir
comptines et donald trump c'était à
l'été 2010 8
finalement les deux chefs d'état vont se
rencontrer à genève en suisse terrain
neutre par excellence afin de tenter de
mettre à plat leurs différents essais
dans la ville à la grange au sein du
parc du même nom que le tête à tête va
avoir vu comme vous pouvez le voir les
autorités locales n'ont pas lésiné sur
la sécurité
en effet deux kilomètres de barrières
métalliques et de barbelés ont été
posées tout autour du parc en question
il faut montrer patte blanche pour
pouvoir pénétrer à l'intérieur
le jour j une partie importante du
centre ville de genève sera complètement
bouclée et la circulation en particulier
au niveau des voies sur berges sera
également interdite les activités
nautiques tout du moins dans cette
partie du lac léman
seront elles aussi proscrite des
milliers de policiers et de soldats sont
présents sur place pour prévenir tout
risque d' attaques terroristes des
manifestations pourraient également
avoir lieu aux abords de la zone
interdite et les autorités locales font
tout leur possible pour que ce moment
historique se déroule sans encombre ce
n'est pas la première fois qu'une
rencontre de ce type est ainsi organisée
à genève en 1985 un sommet réunit c'est
michael gorbatchev et ronald reagan
alors en pleine guerre froide ils se
sont vus entre autres ici au sein de la
mission permanente de la russie auprès
de l'office des nations unies à genève
qui était à l'époque la mission
soviétique
les relations entre les deux pays était
alors passablement détérioré par la
guerre en afghanistan le président
américain venait une politique
volontairement antisoviétique qualifiant
l'urss d'empyr du mal le changement est
venu
avec l'arrivée au pouvoir de miral
gorbatchev leur première rencontre à
genève a posé les fondements de
plusieurs autres au cours desquelles
relations se sont améliorées
deux ans plus tard les deux hommes signé
par exemple le traité sur les forces
nucléaires à portée intermédiaire et en
2021 l'objectif ne sera pas bien
différent tenter d'amorcer le dialogue
dans un contexte de relations entre les
deux pays toujours plus dégradée